YOUR TIME TODAY.
>> Sandra: ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, ED.
WE WANT TO BRING IN FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS JOINING
US IN AN UPDATE ON THE
SITUATION WITH THOSE TWO CRUISE
SHIPS SET TO DOCK IN SOUTH
FLORIDA.
GOVERNOR, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
WHAT IS YOUR ANNOUNCEMENT NOW
AND WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
WITH THOSE PASSENGERS WITH SO
MANY OF THEM HAVING FALLEN HILL.
>> I THINK WE HAVE A PLAN, THE
COUNTY, BROWARD COUNTY WHERE
THE PORT IS WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE CRUISE
LINES AND COAST GUARD TO BE
ABLE TO BRING BOTH OF THOSE
SHIPS IN BUT DO IT IN A WAY
THAT WILL BE SAFE FOR THE
PEOPLE OF FLORIDA.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
FLORIDIANS ON THE ZAANDAM.
WE WANT TO WELCOME THEM AND
HAVE THEM BE SAFE.
THERE IS CONFUSION ABOUT SOME
OF THIS.
THERE IS PROBABLY ANOTHER 2,000
SHIPS OUT THERE.
SOME OF THEM WANT TO COME TO
FLORIDA.
NONE OF THEM HAVE AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THEY’RE ALL FOREIGNS AND WE’VE
BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT IT AS WITH
THE COAST GUARD.
THE ZAANDAM, WE HAVE A PLAN TO
GET OUR FOLKS HOME.
SOME OF THESE OTHER SHIPS OUT
THERE WILL BE A BIG, BIG
PROBLEM BECAUSE IT HAS NO
CONNECTION TO FLORIDA OR TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sandra: AS YOU KNOW,
GOVERNOR, THE HOLLAND AMERICA
CEO IS PLEADING FOR HELP ON
BRINGING THESE SHIPS IN AND
GETTING SOME OF THOSE
PASSENGERS WHO NEED CRITICAL
HELP IMMEDIATELY.
HE SAID IT IS HUMANITARIAN
SITUATION AND CALLING FOR
COMPASSION AND REASON.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO WITH
SOME OF THOSE CRITICALLY ILL
PASSENGERS ON BOARD THOSE SHIPS?
>> WE WORKED WITH THE LOCAL
HOSPITALS AND I KNOW WE HAVE
ONE HOSPITAL THAT’S ABLE TO
TAKE SOME OF THE CRITICALLY ILL.
THEY HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO
THAT.
I THINK IT CAN BE DONE.
THE NUMBERS WON’T NECESSARILY
OVERWHELM.
ONE OF THE MAIN ISSUES WITH
THIS PANDEMIC IS PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO GET INFECTED.
IT’S A RESPIRATORY DISEASE, IT
SPREADS.
WE WANT THE SPREAD TO HAPPEN
SLOWER SO THE SYSTEM DOESN’T
GET OVERWHELMED.
WE WORKED VERY HARD IN FLORIDA.
I THINK WE HAVE MORE
AVAILABILITY OF BEDS THAN WE’VE
HAD IN QUITE SOME TIME.
THAT’S BEEN A LOT OF DILIGENCE.
HOSPITALS ARE WORKING HARD.
WE’VE DONE EXECUTIVE ORDERS TO
DO THAT.
WE’VE PREPARED FOR THIS SURGE
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE BEDS ARE AVAILABLE FOR THE
FLORIDIANS WHO NEED IT.
ON THE ZAANDAM, THOSE FOLKS
WILL GET INTO A HOSPITAL IN
SOUTH FLORIDA AS SOON AS THIS
AGREEMENT IS REACHED.
IT IS THE HUMANITARIAN THING TO
DO.
>> Sandra: THIS IS A PAIR OF
CRUISE SHIPS WE’RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT WILL BE COMING IN TO
DOCK A SHORT TIME FROM NOW
CARRYING MORE THAN 200 GUESTS
AND CREW WITH FLU-LIKE SYMPTOMS.
ONLY EIGHT FROM TESTED POSITIVE
ACCORDING TO THE LATEST REPORTS
IN FRONT OF ME.
MANY OF THOSE OTHER PASSENGERS
COULD BE WALKING AROUND WITH
THE CORONAVIRUS.
ARE YOU GOING TO ALLOW THOSE
PASSENGERS TO GET OFF THE SHIPS
AND WILL THEY BE TESTED?
>> THE AGREEMENT IS THAT
HOPEFULLY ANNOUNCED TODAY ALL
THIS IS GOING TO BE CONTROLLED.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE FOREIGN
NATIONALS.
THEY WILL BE BUSED TO THE
AIRPORT BUT THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO GO INSIDE THE AIRPORT.
THEY GO DIRECTLY TO A PLANE.
FLY TO CANADA AND OTHER
COUNTRIES.
IT WILL ALL BE DONE IN WAYS
THAT ARE NOT GOING TO EXPOSE
THE PEOPLE OF FLORIDA TO ANY OF
THE ILLNESSES THAT MAY BE ON
THERE.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF THINGS
BEING DISCUSSED TO DO THAT.
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE TO BE SAFE
WHEN YOU ARE DOING THIS STUFF.
I THINK THEY FOUND A WAY TO
THREAD THAT NEEDLE AND IF THEY
DID AND THAT ENDS UP THE DEAL
GETS FINALIZED EVERYONE WILL BE
FINE.
WE WOULD BE VERY CONCERNED WITH
A SHIP WHERE THIS ILLNESS IS
CIRCULATING TO JUST BASICALLY
RELEASE PEOPLE INTO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC.
THAT WOULD BE TOTALLY CONTRARY
TO EVERYTHING ELSE WE’RE TRYING
TO DO FOR PUBLIC HEALTH NOT
ONLY IN FLORIDA BUT THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sandra: I’M NOT SURE WHAT
YOU SAID PUTTING THEM ON A
PLANE AFTER THEY GET OFF THE
SHIP AND GOING TO CANADA.
THERE ARE 808 GUESTS ON THE
ROTTERDAM.
583 CREW AND 311 --
>> I WAS TELLING YOU WHAT THE
CRUISE SHIPS ARE PROPOSING TO
DO TO BE ABLE TO GET FOLKS
SAFELY HOME.
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS NO EASY
SOLUTION TO THIS.
YOU CAN JUST LEAVE THEM ON THE
SHIP FOREVER.
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THEY WANT
TO DO.
YOU CAN’T JUST RELEASE THEM
INTO THE GENERAL PUBLIC IF
THEY’VE BEEN EXPOSED.
THEY ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY THEY CAN BE SAFELY
TRANSPORTED TO THEIR COUNTRY OF
ORIGIN WITHOUT HAVING
INTERACTIONS OR CONTACTS WITH
THE GENERAL PUBLIC EITHER IN
FLORIDA OR ANYWHERE ELSE.
SO I THINK THE DETAILS OF THAT
--
>> Sandra: IN THE CASE OF THE
ROTTERDAM, 311 OF THEM ARE
AMERICAN CITIZENS, 52 OF THEM
ARE FLORIDIANS.
>> YES.
WE’RE WORKING ON A PLAN.
I’VE AUTHORIZED THE NATIONAL
GUARD TO SUPPORT LOGISTICS
OPERATIONS AS NECESSARY TO BE
ABLE TO HELP REPATRIATE THE
FLORIDA CITIZENS.
IT HAS TO BE DONE CAREFULLY
WITH SAFETY IN MIND BUT THAT’S
THE BEST WAY TO GO ABOUT IT.
OBVIOUSLY AS GOVERNOR I HAVE AN
INTEREST IN GETTING FLORIDIANS
BACK TO FLORIDA SAFELY AND HAVE
AN INTEREST IN MAKING SURE THAT
IF A FLORIDIAN HAS BEEN EXPOSED
TO THIS VIRUS THEY AREN’T IN A
POSITION TO EXPOSE OTHERS.
ALL THOSE THINGS ARE BEING
WORKED ON.
IT WILL BE DONE CAREFULLY AND I
THINK THAT IS REALLY THE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO DO IT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THESE
CRUISE SHIPS ARE PROBLEMS WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT A RESPIRATORY
CONTAGIOUS VIRUS.
I KNOW THEY STOPPED SAILING.
YOU STILL HAVE SOME OF THE ONES
THAT HAD TAKEN OFF IN MARCH AND
THAT’S JUST THE SITUATION WE
FIND OURSELVES IN.
IF I COULD SNAP MY FINGERS AND
NO ONE WOULD BE ON A CRUISE
SHIP NOW AND ALL AT HOME I
WOULD DO THAT IN A SECOND.
THAT’S NOT THE SITUATION WE
FIND
>> POLICIES GOING FORWARD.
A LOT OF STUFF TWO WEEKS AGO A
LOT OF PEOPLE WERE MAKING
DECISIONS WITHOUT HAVING ANY
REAL FACTS.
WE’RE STARTING TO GET MORE
FACTS IN AND UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE MORE ABOUT THE VIRUS.
WE TRIED TO REACT ACCORDINGLY.
OUR TESTING WE HAVE MORE
NEGATIVE RESULTS THAN ALMOST
ANY STATE.
I THINK NEW YORK MAY HAVE MORE.
WE’LL CONTINUE TO TEST, TEST,
TEST.
THAT’S HOW YOU KNOW HOW TO
COMBAT IT.
>> Sandra: OKAY.
WE WOULD LOVE TO CHECK BACK
WITH YOU AND GET ANOTHER UPDATE
AS CRUISE SHIPS AS THEY COME IN.
GOVERNOR, APPRECIATE YOU COMING
ON THE PROGRAM TODAY.
YOUR POPULATION, SO MANY OF
THEM OVER THE AGE OF 65.
IT’S GOING TO BE A HUGE
CHALLENGE GOING FORWARD.